tell that on rewind ready to make some
enemies let's video we're going on it
Fred this room it's got this movie
fucking duck everybody applauded where
the end cuz they love Jungle Book and
Cinderella and we thought that duck it's
up it's like ever what they can't sing
the people like Stevie shell because
it's not it's not it's a terrible movie
it's dumb at pointless it is such it
just go and see me original classic not
that who is there this movie fucking
suck it sucked
um boom I don't think okay I don't think
that's fair I I will be honest what this
movie did do for me is it did reminds me
of when I was a kid and I was 10 and I
saw Beauty and the Beast and the awe and
the Wonder I had have seen that for the
first time and it really made me want to
go back to then yeah I mean not now but
but this ours it all I mean it didn't
did that it did give me a memory of
being a kid again I was like man it was
really awesome back then it sucks now
the money was gone
did you like the original Beauty and the
Beast you wish you could just erase
those lines as well as the charm this is
the movies for you you are going to be
one of them do you want a near chef I
shall remake of Beauty and the Beast or
born we only with more padding and less
charm - there you go
alright let's do this - let the
structure this is there anyway let's
first talk about the good things in this
movie because I can count them on one
hand
I got yeah I got a couple okay Kevin
fucking Klein right wonderful
casting is part not only perfect casting
the first scene he has with Belle
I turned to Doug and I'm just like names
I said this is I would watch this is
going to be the best scene in the movie
this is not going to get better that and
it never did nope
like he has back story he has four
shared that they ruin
by the way by actually showing it seemed
way different he's different from the
movies different from irezumi Richmond
was just a goof this guy you can see is
a little eccentric but he's he's just
over an awesome nice guy and I'm like I
deserve as I could see mrs. Bell father
I believe they had better she has better
chemistry with her freaking father that
she does with the bean head which is
minoo it will get rid of it yeah um you
know I like what mu I thought he was
legitimately funny okay oh here's my ed
I thought Josh GAD did a great job here
is my provost Lefou why are we calling
him Lefou when he is clearly the smarter
carry like in the original one he where
he was literally like he was the fool he
looks goofy he sounded goofy who does I
guess a lot less like and I'm not saying
you had to do that good but I'm like
let's not call him Lefou graph here's
the food in the and only Dooku's where's
my gay moment I was proud I was promised
all sorts of perversions and a party to
as the state of Alabama I'll say we have
the Alabama version only beefy ality is
okay you can fall in love with a hairy
Hannibal they're okay with that if
they're the same sex you're going to
help Ida late there's a scene where the
guy gets crossdress and he likes it
people applauded they loved it I just
want this either become a joke over here
you're going to hell and the trumpet
good tweet me just felt like theatre
wrong but he's gonna tweet me for the
great thing that I do okay you know
we've got enough garbage to know fellas
suffering human garbage into this okay
okay so it's so easy yeah so for all the
talk but only they share a gay moment
this if you know it's a sure if you're
one of those people who's like uh it is
my right as as I must go see this movie
to make a stand for LDV you you not
script because there is nothing in this
it is like that I more gay and Robin
Hood I've been there yeah there's my
support getting a great mouth
detective Ben Morgan Earp and with
garrison I think air things the Lord of
the Rings like or the ring that blows
this out of the water by the way Alabama
if you showed finding Dory Robin Hood
gray Mouse Detective any of those movies
Joey show decay Disney built okay I mean
Simona my mean since Robin boom I had
three daddy's happy on test two dancing
no three yeah that's a real one is
excessive that's the gay dads so okay um
so yeah so you you if you were going to
see that do you whatever it is you
people all give them value get all up in
arms and something because you wanted to
make a statement and say on for gay
right you got oh because there ain't
jack shit into this movie it's like two
seconds it's about a sexual of fifty
Shades of Grey
yeah there you go um all right uh third
the castle is gorgeous
I like this castle and I okay okay the
interiors are pretty good see we're
having more gay moments now on the frame
elevators
I thought the V impede the interior set
design the successful or if you will of
the Baroque period okay don't fix it I
thought that was pretty good I the
castle just up for on the outside it was
a total crash ooh there was some things
I'm like okay that looks really cooling
off from the other scenes I'm just like
that looks so freakin sheep and like a
bad CGI and then some seems like that
the Sun would be coming up and you get
some color and I'd be like oh no and the
others look here's your crappy blue
filter that we're going to smell around
the connection that they have to the
castle where when a rose petal falls a
little bit of Kappa Falls and they turn
more into an antibiotic which leads to a
great scene at the end that Elizabeth a
bit yeah I mean you know it's sexy yeah
movie again I mean it goes dark I count
them with the castle I I count that with
the cab okay and then ah shit also less
oh uh some of the new songs I like um
and their limit most of it was killer
for me I mean it's not needed but but
they're nice and they're well done um is
there anything else I can to think I
know let's do it Emma watch it good fuck
oh my god
goodbye was painful this is not white
ruffle crow bed but this is insane
teacher it's at least the same cage this
isn't this isn't a Meryl Streep Mamma
Mia bad no but it's we're halfway there
yeah it's like the first three lines
she's saying I'm where we had our own
game oh because I just went like like
that's like home of em boss what the
fuck up was if there is horrible yeah I
just all it like this there would be she
would sing some lines and you could just
hear the truth we were in the very mad
because we knew we were going to be
those dicks and like we're in the very
back yeah you just hear this go oh okay
and how do you know see here's the thing
because like you know there's plenty of
actors in movies they can sing but they
sing and they get through it okay
because we really know because they're
really good actors and they can either
tossing it or the personality is so good
it doesn't matter like like the rock
around it you're really gonna you're
really going to burn this bridge or no
no no okay not going to do it oh good I
go anyways huh so the rockin wanna you
know he's a terrible singer but he
really had that charm and was funny he
made that song work Dwayne the rock jam
playing the rock Johnson yes okay um I
don't think Emma Watson's good actor oh
oh when is she good is she she let her
my knees yeah she was passable yes
you're mine was the best out of that
trifecta but then right back though with
some of the worst at Daniel Radcliffe
whoo how our house Harry Potter you grew
up with it that's why you like what kind
of thing is that's not the better actors
were the older Weasley brothers in
Longbottom yeah I think I got her spot
those main three were they're good baby
it's Emma Watson what the adult and
Harry Potter are good but oh yeah the
strange British actor yeah the kids not
so much uh man I have never seen her in
something where she's like wow you
sucked me in whenever I ran whenever I
see her you are you intrigue me I want
to know I felt like I knew you I felt
like
got your character uh and okay and this
is a character now I love the character
Belle but this is a character that is
honestly in many respects written kind
of flat she's kind of like Superman to
know perfectly but not there because I
don't like the character herself
I may know because this was an example
hugs like you know what what the
animators did in the original was really
frickin good because I'm thinking back
I'm like yo maybe she did add character
at least in the original one because I'm
looking at this performance scene by
scene and I compare these two Belle and
the animators work their ass off I'm
realizing this so that was a good thing
this film did know because it showed me
that the original Comanche I'm like
maybe I was too harsh on Nancy has a
jungle book deal with me I was like wow
and I thought the jungle with the anime
one was okay but if I saw the
live-action piece of shit I'm like wow
maybe maybe I really didn't give this as
big a chance as I should have and I all
love Beauty and the Beast and I'm open
to something different if it ever did
anything different uh maybe I would like
it more every time I see Emma Watson all
I just I just see somebody's like yeah
they read their lines and it was
passable
everyone in this movie nobody is doing
anything because the motivation drives
it because this is what they want to do
they are reading memory because the
first one did it and all we gotta do is
and then when they move things and they
change things around they started all
written and now it does it not make it
better if I had to make less sense okay
example again just this okay this film
really fucking makes me appreciate how
much it makes me appreciate that I
appreciate animation and I don't see it
as just kid stuff I'm like wow the
effort the time frame by frame we have
exactly a real animated film that had no
live-action humans that have had more
emotion and passion in it than this yes
okay cool yeah okay and a first ok first
scene where I knew they weren't going to
get it they were not gonna get what made
the film special and what may sell
special for two frames for me but he
kind of oh really that early on cause
when he comes out what color is she
wearing
I don't know then what color is Eloise
wear it oh look yeah uh well in the end
a movie wore blue in the animated movies
uh well the Beast anyone else uh a guest
on was read nobody L know what I get
with us that was done so that she stands
out both visually and as a character
half the people weren't ruinous
immediately okay that's fair enough
attending on with block but I guess
immediately again this never really took
care in making her stand out and not
necessarily flaunting it in your face
because you know you see her she's
reading she's doing her own thing this
one she's trying to get the look ten
yeah I don't know that we're dropping
says she has a you know that thing um
and they're trying to shove in your face
but again she can't pull it off and she
doesn't have a good singing voice and
she doesn't have the charm that you know
I can't phone kitty has the right keys
that is the extensive it called
auto-tune it yeah I like that they heard
singing range is just she can hit the
right keys can she hold a note for any
length of it no she'd been she doesn't
know she sing costs her way through the
whole movie and you and now the ultimate
it no no I get okay because it's just
piss my wife sob with us and now she
would be the target audience she's like
I want to see this movie I was telling
she's like I was six sheets poison yeah
she was like I'm six years old when the
original came out and and the ideas are
gonna be so cool and this is my
childhood she fucking hated it
and I love the enemy I said and she when
it comes to adult seeing this she's the
target audience um so she didn't like it
well but by she does what Kitty pointed
okay no no should pointed this out one
of the most winningest if my wife puts
this Tony Award winners Audra McDonald
is in this movie and she is in the first
freaking scene singing one of the great
voices of our time and what did she do
she ends up playing the fucking Wardrobe
who according to the plot falls asleep
all the time so she has inherited sing
so she's in the beginning of the movie
for like five seconds she occasionally
things like five lines somewhere in the
rest of them and she's at the very end
of the film so the one person in this
whole fucking movie who can actually
sing barely things at all and there's
Emma Watson running around sing talking
with the robot fixing her voice and even
what she does you when she does sing
they do it like this over that oh wow oh
it's supposed to sound kind of goofy and
over the top and I'm heart and like that
sells out it better that's that's where
I was like when we got to the end of the
movie nice saw Barry because they all
come back to life and says Raya I'm was
like hey that's right Audra McDonald was
in beginning this way and she sings like
two lines from the you know Taylor and
I'm like okay cool finally some real
singing and then it comes to the other
Emma who isn't that great either playing
the teapot finishing the song mi are you
fucking kidding me she can't even finish
the fucking song I was fuck your movie I
that was insulting I am insulted that
you even frickin busy you put a singer
that good and surround her with people
who can sing fuck you now family I'm on
ok yeah no that's trust me like I said
we are just because my ears is still
bleeding
and uhm ok again with mo what if you
couldn't sing there are extras that can
pull it off it would be unbelievably
difficult to do that with a character
like Belle because you're supposed to
have a really good voice but maybe it
could work to BSM charm but and maybe
it's not necessarily her fault but
because the lobby are actors in the
scene for example um as a scene she
finds out her father's in trouble she
says my father is in trouble beef you
must go get him fucking wait a minute
ok cuz this is what the animes the MA
movie done it has fucking Humanity in
these drawings in these lines because
when she says my father's is my father's
in trouble keep stop he turns to the
road he touches it he looked at it he
looks up he cradles it he says then he
must go to him and that is like five
different emotions in five seconds oh no
you are bowing to me who skips all of
the how about the first scene where she
sees the rose and then the original
she's like well she's like taking the
top off she's like looking and
everything and this one she like
guess within 40 feet of it obviously ya
know ya do anything okay originally and
again we have to compare it because this
is trying so hard no your don't really
don't you see it's trying to you so down
here shot remake yeah I am naughty I
think it's insulting me if I try to
grind it what is perfect somebody's
dying somebody's trying to tell me that
on my public Facebook that like well you
should just forget the other one I'm
like well okay for one thing it was the
Best Picture nominee one of the animated
Best Picture nominees picture now and
that we can do it better
you're making a practical shit like it's
not Gus Van Sant's psycho bad but it
gets close to the number of scenes
you're practically making a shot by shot
remake and now you're telling me like
some Zen riddle now forget you ever saw
the original I can't you're reminding me
of the original every single second even
if I didn't see the original I never saw
the end I'm not very good oh I would say
like now they don't have any chemistry
why are they doing no can no can
everything in the animated film
naturally moves forward the motivations
connect you see how they get from A to B
to C to D all the way to the end this
one it's like why are they doing acid on
and Lefou has more chemistry the belt
and bound to be totally um he has the
only person she has any even close to
chemistry with is your father which is
very strange like I don't know what that
says about story but I've got bestiality
in this it was well so uh okay and I
mean the opening they're doing the
backstory which they show and it's like
okay be a little different that's my
line for line they're doing the
narration and you know he says you know
the enchantress comes in and he
dismisses her okay he seems dismisses
her you know she says but I warn you you
know beauty lies within if she never
moved her mouth but whatever and if she
starts turning to the Enchantress and
when the and when he dismissed her again
he didn't do that and then it's like you
know the Prince tried to apologize no
she didn't and literally everything in
this movie has to stuff they're saying
they're doing and they're not doing it
Belle comes in when her father is
captured by the Beast and she's supposed
to look down see
whenever he's walking stick or whatever
it is and okay normal actor would look
down pick up the stick a couple like
that and move forward this one that's it
is it
it is a sign number is what I would say
without that Roenick considering the
animated film like yeah in paper plane
and quick you don't hear enough they go
here now you think that's like they say
that what you think this all where we
play a video game
they really feel that the goddamn video
game I feel even a guy being video game
would have more charm than this
alright I played video games that were
way better than this yeah no I know and
with more human emotion yeah uh right
just random things that they did they
just skipped like I turn to you and I
turn to my wife and I'm like bail like
watches her father get dragged away by
the Beast and I was like who's going to
be fine like but you're going to be
prisoner here whatever I was like okay
that's the last we see the father for a
while the father eventually stumble then
you know and they do that whole bedroom
I got captured by beasts I'm like okay
Bell ride back at the end of Sabre
father on the horse I'm like well if
she's got the horse how the hell did he
get home the animated film actually
showed you and then they just skip it I
feel better than that they make these
characters so goddamn dumb that there's
literally seeing the enemy well where he
says what do you think I'm an idiot
because you know the candle says do you
think maybe you go to would be the ones
who break this valley of course I have
I'm not fool and in this one he doesn't
show her to the room he doesn't take her
out he has the candlestick and the clock
come in takers they say all the wet
spring all the silo it's possible onto
the beast they give to them and it will
live a lot of that beast dialogue wrong
and I think in a lens of a connection
with me and then they talk to the Beast
later and they're like hey but what you
gave her her own room you're inviting
her down to dinner like what maybe this
could be the one to win her over
what oh I don't know is they the anime
one point about what a fucking dumbass
this is you know I mean it's like I'm
pointing out all these problems because
the anime one where like they you know
what we may be a kid's film but we
really try and make something really
good and really tight
good claret other strange random they
like Daisy as they were moved lines
valid from the beats but like let's okay
cuz when you expand the B's character
guys here's what we're going to do turns
out well guess you've got a tragic
backstory and it's totally pointless and
it's just they deliver these like
throwaway lines like well it's all
fogged area see because his father
abused them and we didn't stop it I'm
like okay I hope this goes somewhere
well we see in this song flashback him
standing over is like mothers like
deathbed and then the father comes up
behind the little prince to be beast and
like turns them around and walks away my
where's this going nowhere have you
never seen a single that I just like
what that's it you bring up this whole
tragic bastard that's all you frickin
show no because what we have to do is
cut back the Emma Watson singing no no
okay so but it's okay because I guess
there's a connection because those
mothers I - well okay but and you see
kevin kline kept this a secret i firmly
yes don't really get like very first
time with a grade and then they keep
trying to explain it more yeah
everything I needed to know you said
that first scene again completely
quality behind in child versus what is
okay but the best scene is when you know
they're out there they're connecting
they're both reading which I like I
think that's a nice thing they can
connect with um and you know and just
talk about being sickness canceling
everything he says let's run away huh
and I'm like where are we going like
okay baby I'll bite where are you taking
us and so he says I'll take the bait
since the sorceress on top of a magic
mirror and you know this magic Rose also
left another little magic thing here
it's a magic book and he sets up like
there's like it's a cruel joke because I
could go anywhere I want but I can't
because I'm a beast and people would
like you know poke stick Sabir so big I
was like I mean cancerous just thinking
really hard about this like she's a bit
right yeah everybody her extra cruzi has
this book seconds and like and even help
and I get cuz like your take on that
extra stuff so this book opens up and
put your
not Kay think of where you want to go so
she goes through her childhood home the
tiny little place and they're just there
okay
yes I've been there there they're fake
if you want to they can go anywhere in
the world
okay now this - okay - oh and by the way
you never see them go anywhere again no
it's just like my complaint about the
animated film and I love we joke a she's
got back home very original but my one
kind of little gripe about the animated
film was like a little bit propellers
are alive I'm gonna counsel like but I'm
not for sure and get the shit about
spoiler spoiler alert yeah I saw Tony
richer I thought for sure that once they
open this book of mine okay that's
awesome this fixes the prom on the
animate them cuz now they have this book
and then go anywhere they want maybe the
movies gonna end with them exploring
some far-off place on the planet ER or
something you're going don't book you've
never brought up again this dark Shelley
room so there's two there's two things
about this one oh okay there's multiple
things but the two that stuck out for me
one did it occur to you know how we have
gone full fucking circle cuz what
everybody say about BioShock Infinite oh
my god Elizabeth is just like that
and now we're sitting here in the beauty
of the be screaming and Belle has the
fucking powers of Elizabeth wave your
hand and now we can go to parents y'all
holy shit look at this go full circle so
that's one thing I just laugh my ass off
like a BioShock Infinite reference in
beauty movies to the thunk the second
thing is lighter later that they do the
same thing where it's just like oh I'm
worried about my father's like oh well
right have this magic boo that will show
you it's like okay show me my father oh
no my father's in trouble he's in
trouble I have to go okay then I set you
free what did she do she rides up on the
horse said I wanted a dress by the way
dress doesn't even take the dress so I'm
like okay well obviously she didn't take
the dress up because she is in such a
fucking hurry to get there because her
poor father gonna be holding if she
can't get there and done who knows
what'll happen I'm just sitting there
thinking called by the fucking boss
fucking Punk
just saying just wave him take me to
where my father's being all the way
taken to the village and instead she
rock the beat can go anywhere he can go
into the woods he can build a captain he
can go anywhere uh-uh-uh never the
gnostics can go anywhere and they go
through this shitty dark little room to
find out that she didn't have a mother
which oddly they going from really
connect that much say I'm not having a
mother it's pretty goddamn how I thought
I would have my mother's you going up a
blurred boy we were like okay but
everything he said are we implied either
she died in childbirth or she died of a
disease that's something I think there
was I think I forget to have hot left oh
god help me I tell you what kills you've
up an early scene too with her in her
father which was the best thing in the
movie as I said multiple times now is it
was the best visual storytelling you
learned everything you could about her
father with the seasons on the walls the
drawings he was making the selfie was
I'm just like I'm sorry it's the rest of
the movies like this we're going to be
okay nope
they also move certain scenes around
alas Dom tries to just fucking up and
kill Maurice yeah like they basically
just tie them up in the woods that are
just like oh what the wolves eat them
and like the foo is no Lefou bothers
visa character to because they try to
make him sympathetic but I'm like you
still sat there let us do that and
Annemarie scumbags like you tried to
fucking kill me and it is like a gasp Oh
foo and lapooh run across like yeah like
no I know we didn't try to kill and I
just looked but so the first movie will
move things around like for example uh
you know just pads it
yeah what does it it makes it slower
again you just fucking appreciate the
painting of the original miss another
one okay
well I like this one because it starts
off okay
the Abell father goes off you know - we
don't even really know do we in the
original hero I feel like I'm already
met this for the once behind that's how
bad why why was he leaving we see a pack
up the little clock I don't even
remember you go salad I don't know maybe
explain it but that's especially well
names just the language though you want
me to get anything from the marketplace
a ruse like I always ask okay I and I
like these a CVS you take the wrong I
chose one but okay so anchor room after
she leaves what happens we follow him he
goes to the castle there's the Beast all
the stuff goes down and comes back to
her and guests on as the wedding ready
and stuff like that she goes into the
big singing the song over the landscape
okay that follows immediately after the
father leaves so when she goes up there
and things I want adventure the great
white somewhere that beautiful landscape
this time we have dark clouds and
thunderstorms and stuff like that I'm
like I know I'll ask it I wasn't I don't
know what adventure there no hatred like
completely ruined this they allow me her
thinking alright okay but I need this
just immediately ruin the ocean was
working overdrive there that one came
out alright okay yeah beautifully robot
after be our gift you know beer guys you
Romero happy plazas oh that was
fantastic okay so you tore the capital I
sure and the characters were coffee
children just oh what's in the West Wing
oh nothing nothing is dusty this oh so
that's the West Wing again a little
character why would you want to go up in
everything with this as you can see our
gas black yes why am I here why it's
just walking and you have I wasn't it
was three or four times it just cuts to
black but brilliant Oh fucking in a liar
did you want a hominid rider mister
Chicago which is another movie I didn't
like all that much there's what so like
you could just tell like I'm so proud of
I'm gonna end we're gonna stage a
Pakistan coin
let's boom like
and this is where the crowd would
applaud we had silence in ours they did
a plot at the end of the movie and I was
just like all wrong great money you
remember how many times we kept the
black in the original I think it was
what builds after Maurice is taken away
and I got door closes so that singles
the black and then you see a peeking out
of the bushes like oh that's like really
clever for a feed thousand the darkness
fades up through the voices but at least
of our sipping in clever they've been as
you do that cuz you want to look it was
really fucking well paced and it felt
very natural very flowing this one case
so Duncan so so the original one you
know they basically Maurice runs in just
like guys the bees yeah well help the
auto man kick them out and just laugh
ooh I'm afraid I've been thinking you
know we're gonna make everybody think
he's nuts and then next time you yeah
and then a quick scene just like so I'm
gonna pay you to make you think of it
okay
and then at the end when Belle comes
back because the father's just sick
after trying to come back like he's like
we're gonna haul them away unless you
marry me like these are quick little
scenes this one is like will you help me
and all the time guess sounds like
alright I'll help you and I'm like okay
where we go yeah like a long ass scene
searching through the woods ruzek I
don't know the magic must not be the
same and there's the tree but I can
guess sounds like I'm sick of this is a
few kind of funny bits with that but cuz
I'm like okay and then kevin kline
basically says I'm never going to let
you marry my daughter and I guess dumb
punches him like okay and then they
leave him tied to a tree in the middle
of the woods for the wolves to get I'm
like mmm okay and then this old good old
woman who somehow is working in the bar
comes and saves and drags kevin kline
back helps nurse him back okay then
kevin kline goes back to the bar and
says you tried to kill me again look at
Gaston thank ya stuff of no I didn't
then what moves like nine didn't and
something they're just like obviously
you're nuts we're going to have you
committed
and then Belle sees them through the
mirror trying to have them committed and
instead of going through the book ride
the fucking horse and then we have
the yellow diamond in the yellow dress
that we have a whole fucking song
sequence as she's leaving and I just put
this movie goes on for fucking ever for
something that the animated film
accomplished with like I don't know 14
laughing and again five minutes and
again the drawings on them you
immediately saw the expressions you saw
what was going on inside their head is
such quick poignant clever lines are
just like you don't need them like you
just need these few lines need to get
right to the point and you need they
need to be very important that I need to
be very very focused with this one's one
guests on is life you know it she's like
you know that really wasn't be look and
shows you know but a mere there uh you
just don't look at that it isn't evil
yes like where is this coming from the
other one where like yeah I was like you
would ceiling for his mozzie sugar well
why did you Arnie but honey finally see
if you know I can't hear you nobody can
let's kill the person you love you know
they did it he wants you to really do it
where this go from yeah and that is like
he wants to spend on the lines or we're
doing like this piece was an existential
threat to us all gugus build them all
around me but make it today for another
guy you guys are gonna make commentary
like they're by the way movie mixes
Petofi sailing with the gay bit like
make it a better movie then like it's
just so another example okay
the famous viewing the Beast dancing now
and they want to grow up with this movie
I mean can show more dress poor and hope
you like you to Cinderella cuz your guys
you're a watcher put on a dress at 40
minutes on every bit of glitter and go
yeah magic glitter gold comes down Audra
McDonald back she has one line and like
now would have this happen moons a
wardrobe by the way fucking creepy
dancing is supposed to be charming I'm
like it has no eyes it has these little
dark old turaga creamy mouth I'm just oh
you are unplayable I don't ask you
they're all creepy they're all miscast
I should say all miscast long run cosmic
we're okay oh that's a girl
fucking ask them with Ewan McGregor
doing well what's that I don't know
question spit that was route Spanglish I
don't know what the hell he was doing
when I was at frelich Kevin Klein's is
technically work if he's trying to do
British and it only comes in every other
end of a sentence
I believe the crazy old man okay okay
well I was getting too so yeah okay no I
do want to say this but I don't like
Bernie and miquelon Ian McKellen as cogs
words didn't work
I didn't most of them just didn't really
work for me I was like they don't have
really Cochran had a great personality
in the original and this well they are
not better yeah in terms of just one no
they're okay I'm Google who there's open
grumpy yes it's 12 o'clock okay all I
got at it okay but so the big beauty in
the piece off ways you know it's famous
famous see how is it open opens with
them on either side as they come down
and they start going down the stick and
the little dog barks of them Oh already
a little off a little quirky but okay
they go and they have dinner they sit
down and he's trying to eat you know
like a civilized guy and then she gets
an idea she gets up and sees that plate
below she grabs them take them to the
ballroom she's still nervous goal and
she's kind of showing on my dad and
she's kind of teaching him and they gets
into it and man that just so naturally
worked up this one they walk down the
stairs into the ballroom
they dance stare blankly at each other
and pale imitation of Angela Lansbury
wearing pajamas they are doing it
because they did it in the original and
there is no motivation nothing you know
compels them to go into that do call
room she only didn't go into that whole
night with no food they are both going
through a whole night with no food I
think I mean okay since you got there
because the whole joke and the beer
guess something that she doesn't eat
yeah that's it done bad the only thing I
liked about that scene was like okay it
was nice to be the ballroom kind of done
a little updated because that scene is
not held up well it is every vgi in the
original yeah the ballroom surrounding
band I think is okay so to ps2 fun I
think it's a letter no it doesn't it
doesn't
the movie the original movie but uh my
guys kind of cool to see the ballroom
kind of updated but that's the same with
tiny with all the chandeliers there and
even okay what even then a lot of things
I thought was kind of cool if the
instruments on the wall start playing
thanks really clever one shot gone yeah
everything is like why why don't you
respond with that why don't you explore
that it felt like there was no exploring
in this film if any you've got a whole
capital to explore yeah and you know
wasn't allowed there's a neat idea or
you know something a little funny what's
a lot of movie got a laugh out of me but
aside from that I mean it is just so
lifeless and so devoid of end up anyway
here is mine is likely it's just
watching these mannequins one of them
teaching the other to and yet somehow
you swear they were switched because of
how lifeless they are and they just are
to save your life like well I remember
this in those of the cartoon why are we
doing this again you're not doing it as
good
it's paint-by-number if they had a
picture of Beauty and the Beast they had
all the numbers mark and you just paint
it and there it is and it's like oh not
quite as good but I recognize that as
beauty of these things like number
versus paint by passion yeah what paint
by passion literally paint and doing a
paper number divinity like DaVinci did
the original now you're designer the
original reaped off the screen I mean it
just felt like it was alive in itself a
lot faster than that yeah and I'm just
like fine
and it was joyful and it was just so
much fun and it was romantic it was
suspenseful it was funny it was musical
and everything felt like it felt
brand-new even though it was using a
formula that we've seen before you know
sir the Disney I was I was like this I
stand by what it did take me back to
when I was a kid and I thought oh this
movies off yeah but but that's only
because this movie was not I won't say
this movie will make you love Beauty and
the Beast
yeah it will you have you already love
it you will love it get times more um
okay oh one last what the fuck then I'll
bring up in this is that again that
we're kind of getting the spoilers but
it's pretty much the animated one just
some bad you can't spoil anything
but it's really not giving anything away
the woman that nurses kevin kline again
for the bartender whatever here's your
chance
yeah but so now he's an entirely
pointless but there's a scene where
Gaston is like you know because gimmick
line does not I know you're out there I
don't know their size Honest Abe well
well who you gonna trust this bowl hey
hot food believe her to be in center
cook bitch
Yahoo oh mai gerd hold my drink Pete you
know and it's like why did that know he
has to go in the Townsville burn get
down alive
no no but yes yes no he has to go and
really shoot the fuck out of bees on me
he really offers quite a bit it Islam an
idiot and turns into biotech in
committee he's just he'd bathroom I
fucking Booker just and then he he falls
off quit not even bringing back any of
the characters that he pissed off I
think I'm a foods got some to do with it
or about the Enchantress cuz no no I was
a gay seeing that they could talk about
those look food was going to be there it
gets out funny like who could buy in
prison
I feel like a chum it out and drop and
then at the end with my car so as you
turn to be like f there's like wait a
second like duty and crib before the end
credits ran you were just like if the
Enchantress just renders a guest on I
guess I'm totally called am a hag and
said no offense whatever maybe that was
good if it's no offense yes call me I'm
there and I just started churches I'm
like well he did die how convenient
could you see into the future on an S I
mean it's just okay oh so um we clearly
didn't like this movie I actually think
you hated it more than I did I will save
this it was a precious at the beginning
but if he made it this far
um we're taught no I I will say uh going
into this I was not looking forward to
seeing this movie honestly it looks like
a tell you the paint-by-number they'll
pretty much the movie if I was going to
give it's in the made even less sense
and fifty cynical rehab
it's a lifeless rehash um and so I went
in with this idea that this is was going
to be like if you're going in like I
want to see if I want to love it no
matter what you will love it no matter
what
Oh half the crowd did know a lot of it
yeah they bought it and she raised a
neurotic I better I felt like I felt
like Knox from the Batman movie when the
parade's going down and they're all
grabbing the money I'm like look at them
pick the pictures just me greed ah
you felt like that little red
riding-hood for the book buddy Cartman
that's really obscure um but if if I was
a little kid and I knew the anime
wide-load live-action one coming up I
would want to see it because BEC eyes so
I think it's just interesting I like
comparing live-action to animated
incising a lot of kids do and I think a
lot of adults do too so he's going mad
with that mindset he'll probably live it
fry is that that's their first exposure
I hope a you know night oh wait na the
original one introduced their kids to
this before the anime one nobody well I
mean it depends oh oh they aren't it
depends if their parents had gotten a
table of doctors me vault first that
that Disney buting beef is everywhere
you can see our roommate I like the
Marvel movies I've liked some of the
Star Wars and then there's some of the
stuff Disney's done in the animated
realm reasonably good but this is maybe
the most pissed off I've been at Disney
in a while where I'm just like no fuck
you
the does near a cube the Disney remakes
heavy
the Disney people they are the business
people yeah some are passable
I thought Cinderella was passable no
sinner oh is it you know what here think
I appreciate - why so many things about
Cinderella but that's the thing at least
it was doing something different happens
I'm like I made out of like it but I'm
like you know what you tried something
different yeah like this one there's
some a little bit different what is
different just is filler and then the
stuff make changes like in the jungle
book where it's like well you have made
pretty much nothing better and you might
find a things work my favorite so far
has been Pete's dragon I just saw him
last night I'm just like you know what
this is not a perfect movie by any
certain magic but I'm just like what
mono this has in common with the
original beeps dragons there's a boy
named Pete and there's a dragon that is
I'm like oh so you actually did a remake
and really just like trust the old when
I was like all right let's try our own
thing I have not seen at home but I you
know I respected it for that this though
like Pete frags Goodman even way worse
than it was I still would probably
respected mum like you don't want
anything new than this you know what it
didn't do well and we know this one the
show we saw was practically sold out and
it's um they're gonna keep doing them
shot by shot so all of us address I hope
you like what I was I won't say this my
favorite scene that they never did like
I was just waiting for cuz she she rides
off still in the giant yellow dress and
the guy running the insane is of is
hauling kevin kline out in the business
the crazy wagon and belle rides up in
the yellow dress and the guy like and
the insane as of Magid just is like and
then he just wanted to say where did you
get back yet nobody's already kind of
address at me the point is for nobody
addresses all maybe that's why he's here
in the loony bin too because they're
just like okay nobody just rides the
horse out nowhere comes in so if there's
an animal dressed like that
I'm sorry your your enough difference I
went into the more thing but um but yet
if you're going in really wanting to
just see a shot-for-shot remake of a
classic and you just want to go people
try to sing with our with four new songs
of which one's pretty good and the other
three are right
um yes mess about that huh with people I
can't really sing them that well but you
know they try hard enough and you've got
an amazing Broadway singer who sings
about like seven line I really think the
people are going to like this movie are
going in wanting to really love and
that's not a bad thing that's not
something I figure stupid no not at all
you really want guy and like I think
Doug we have found the real Stockholm
Syndrome um keep me a prisoner but know
if you're looking at this thinking I'm
not gonna like this you're not you're
probably going to hate it in fact if I
do love the original we're on the kid
makes it better
you're right they can't yes the mouse
can do no wrong for you and I don't
begrudge the kids who were sitting there
and had a good time though I feel like
the kids were bored at some point I do
feel like when I remember seeing over
where it is I feel like we were laughing
all the time and it was kind of raucous
this time I feel like there were a lot
of dry spells I'm sure the kids love it
at the same time we're going so if
you're a kid or if you're just like
Disney can do no wrong take me now go
enjoy enjoy but if you're sitting on the
fence like this it's kind of like going
on a clinical cash grab it okay yeah and
don't give her a real love cynical cred
when they're done well yeah we
definitely have so I mean we are not
above that IME my favorite movie a
couple years ago with still guarding to
Macau yeah I had a hot item are my keys
is it up this just pop-culture delicious
candies trash I love it like I love this
give me more mama that movies amazing
but it's not like is everybody likes a
fun
it's not sort of them came they don't
know exact abuse is it no so that's
saying is SB Citizen Kane I can like a
lot of so what I wouldn't leave settle
for beauty in the beach yeah not too
greedy I'll settle for that Oh settle
for a film I got the best pictures just
okay yes well I'll bet a thousand bucks
says here's what the ultimate insults
going to be watch watch this happen talk
and watch it happen this thing's going
to get nominated for an Academy Award
for one of the side things like art
design or something and I will fucking
win and from now on we'll have to say
Academy award-winning live-action Beauty
and the Beast while the original
animated once in win well I have gotten
song I'd be very good at anything wrong
I'm a oh god if it didn't also look that
up go go go look at those there okay
there's no there's good type it anyway
just go look it up to go talk um okay um
so yeah pretty much what he said if you
feel like you're gonna love this movie
and you just wanna go the mouth can do
no Rhonda you will and good for you
really go enjoy it you know it nothing
left you at all but yeah haha it was
best original music score yes all right
fuck it like that no lethal be tied so
um yeah there it is
sorry I know people are gonna hate us
but we don't do this boo boo talk baby
talk - so mom listen anything go I don't
yeah now we just we discussed there's
like he gets out that I got up next - I
was like uh he's just like care to make
a lotta enemies tonight and then people
off do it so we look forward to your
hate mail